that's exactly how it goes down because
i was having flashbacks i'm letting you
guys know this is
this is real
[Music]
hi my name is mario i'm a former
convicted felon i served 12 years in
corcoran state prison for home invasion
robbery i've seen a whole lot of things
in prison
and today i'm here to review scenes from
various prison movies and tv shows
let's get it no no don't i'll peas
you want cake just peas to milk
okay at the child hall chow hall is
where you get your food
nine times out of ten a lot of people
like to make their own food if you can
afford it you know you don't supposed to
take food back to yourself that's
to consider contraband
she's stepping on a bag of chips
crunching them up real fine and good
so we use chips we open them and we
crunch them up like this
a little water yes i remember this we
call them spreads their spread is like
gumbo
a lot of different foods put together
sometimes you ought to cook
uh your food one by one because you're
only limited to
one microwave give me four shrimp
promise sold out
she said she sold out with the ramens
jesus who put all the ramens i
the guy i'm the guy that done this i am
the one who bought
all the ramen to all the snickers out
the store because i rented two for one
store for those who know what that is
that mean
whatever you want from me i will give it
to you and when you go to store next
you give me two of them back scale 105
judging that scene i watched on orange's
new black
i give it a four the reason being is
because it really happens when people
buy up the conversation if they have
opportunity or the financial
uh money to do so
[Music]
hell no you're not gonna you're not
gonna be doing push-ups with your
drawers that's not a regular day it's
fictional
respect is so important in prisons
because that's all you have
especially with your cellmate just
somebody you're living with 24 hours a
day
so you just want a certain time you can
work out job rather when your cellmate
is out the sale or is when he's on his
bed that dude is
doing push-ups in draws what's real
about the scene
is nothing as far as comedy yeah it was
funny because
people have been in jail look at this is
funny because they exaggerated rating
this scene from one to five i already
won as far as being real or not
i'll let you guys know this is this is
real
and this hobby tension on the yard
nobody's playing basketball
nobody playing pineapple that's a card
game we play on the yard at the tables
oh yeah that's like a cracker and then
there's pandemonium everywhere
but yeah this is this is realistic again
as far as the camera been in the middle
of a riot watching people
fight if a guard sees a weapon by law
they have a they have a right to shoot
you with the mini 14.
off top i would say there's nothing
official about the scene i would say
that whole
scene is real that's exactly how it goes
down and i was trying to walk you
through as i was watching it
because i was remembering the
and having flashbacks that's exactly how
it happens with the tension
and everything rating this team from
shockwater 105 i would give it a five
from the beginning to the end of the
scene i can relate to it throughout
they walk it in seems like to a visit
and she
is smuggling something into prison it's
a federal offense for
anyone to transport or traffic anything
on a federal ground three it counteracts
the sedative effects of the cape
making your idea and what's crazy though
is you push back
unbelievable what's crazy about this is
a lot of people know
who the smuggler is coming to prison
it's you don't post a note but everybody
know because everybody excited george is
coming in here
like whatever your of choice is if it's
weed you know who the weedman is so when
he going to visit
you'd be happy he just swallowed it so
you can swallow some
you gotta double triple balloon it and
let it go through
and when you get back to yourself you
have two options regurgitate it and
throw it back up
or you go playing yo all right boo boo
you can play little boo boo nice
guys i understand you have to do it but
if you're caught for this
the case is over it's hard to give
advice to people that's inside the malls
when you outside
and this and this is part of survival to
fit us that's probably him surviving
right there so that was actually a real
scene a solid five
all the way through all that was real
he's shoveling through the wall
[Music]
i've never heard of anyone digging a
hole through a wall or anything inside
of prison grounds
only thing i can relate to with that is
digging under a gate in prison to
retrieve uh contraband such as weapons
cell phones we'll have somebody from the
outside who's free
drive three or four hours up to that
specific location
that's how we retrieve different type of
contraband
i want you this is a good thing not
tomorrow not after breakfast
now yes sir
so when somebody escaped or they
realized after count the count went
right they locked everything down
wherever you're at
you can be in church in prison you can
be in school you can be on a visit they
like everybody down here right down the
cell they do a standing man count
a stanton man count is when they want
everybody in a two-man cell
to be with your lights on clothes
and standing in the middle of your cells
so the officer can physically see that
there's two people in that cell
and prison scapes are not common because
you have electric gate
you have guards with towers with machine
guns that's on every post of the prison
i give the movie shawshank redemption i
said i give it a three
because the escape part of the movie i
think it's a little exaggerated
that it may have been the wardens are
counting but didn't fool him in the end
i did 12 years in prison and i'll be
sitting here lying to you if i told you
it wasn't hard
it's something that uh i had to go
through now that i'm out of prison i'm
experienced and i try to
uh tell people is you have to surround
yourself
with the people you want to be around
you got to surround yourself with
positivity
sometimes you don't want to go with the
fast dime it's okay to have a slow
nickel
you